[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paradies samstagabend will kommt
zu den nachrichten im sport hat norbert
könig unter anderem fußball für sich
genommen was uns in dieser sendung an
großen themen beschäftigt das sehen sie
jetzt
politischer spagat fdp chef lindner
stark dem kanzler den rücken
gleichzeitig fordert er auf dem
parteitag schwere waffen für die ukraine
schwere kämpfe in der ost ukraine
russland nimmt viele städte unter
dauerbeschuss die offensive kommt aber
offenbar nur langsam voran und
weniger hass und hetze im netz die eu
einigt sich auf ein gesetz das internet
konzerne bald stärker regulieren soll
schwere wachmann die ukraine liefern ja
oder nein diese frage beschäftigt auch
die fdp auf ihrem parteitag
parteichef christian lindner ist dafür
und gibt sich überzeugt die ukraine wird
diesen krieg gewinnen
gleichzeitig stellte sich lindner hinter
kanzler scholz dem beil
waffenlieferungen der zögerlichkeit
vorgeworfen wird über eine schwierige
balance britta buchholz aus berlin
die ukraine dominiert den parteitag
schon am morgen junge liberale prangern
die bisherige politik gegenüber russland
an besonders im fokus die verbindung der
spd die fdp will per antrag die
lieferung von waffen und rüstungsgütern
festlegen der antrag ist dezidiert
deutlich dass wir schwere waffen liefern
das wie kaskaden haft rausgehen aus der
energie- und ich glaube ist ein
wichtiges zeichen der parteitag
diskutiert stunden über die wege in
diesem konflikt lindner wegen einer
corona erkrankung nur digital
zugeschaltet mahnt gemeinsam mit den
nato partnern zu handeln wir müssen
alles was in unserer macht steht tun um
der ukraine zum sieg zu verhelfen
aber die verantwortungs ethische grenze
ist die gefährdung unserer eigenen
sicherheit
gleichzeitig nahm er dem bundeskanzler
demonstrativ in schutz scholz habe das
vertrauen der gesamten fdp kritik vor
allem an der union der parteipolitische
manöver vorwirft
emotional wurde der neue fdp
generalsekretär
er kam als 11 jäger ohne eltern während
des irak krieges nach deutschland
diejenigen menschen die in ihrem leben
einen krieg persönlich miterleben
mussten wie beispielsweise derzeit die
menschen in der ukraine
wissen für den rest ihres lebens welches
schreckliche leid krieg mit sich bringt
und wie wertvoll frieden ist
gewählt mit 89 prozent ein deutliches
signal
auch am abend dominiert die ukraine dem
parteitag die debatte um die
waffenlieferungen dauert zur stunde noch
an
und vor ort beobachtet ralf schumacher
für uns den parteitag greift das sind ja
wirklich widersprüchliche signale der
fdp auf der einen seite will man weiter
druck machen für die lieferung schwerer
waffen ralf ich hoffe du kannst uns
hören ich stelle die frage noch mal ja
das sind ja wirklich widersprüchliche
signale die man da von der fdp mit
bekommt auf der einen seite wollen die
liberalen druck machen bei der lieferung
schwerer waffen auf der anderen will man
den koalitionsfrieden waren wir wollen
die liberalen diesen spagat meistern
tja die fdp die sicherheits treibende
kraft in der ampel die ukraine soll
offensive unterstützt werden auch mit
schweren waffen aber im rahmen von
bündnis absprachen und ohne die
bundeswehr zu schwächen christian
lindners deutliches bekenntnis zum
kanzler und zur koalition bremst allzu
forsche forderungen aus den eigenen
reihen und ist zugleich an der abfuhr an
die union die frage der
waffenlieferungen im bundestag als
machtprobe mit der regierung zu
inszenieren winter waren vor
parteipolitischen manövern und mahnt zur
versachlichung der debatte und trotzdem
die fdp als kleinster ampel partei ringt
um ihre rolle und immer wieder auch um
aufmerksamkeit prescht vor gibt kontra
zeigt sich unnachgiebig aktuell sicher
ein stück weit den wahlkämpfen in
schleswig holstein und nordrhein
westfalen geschuldet auf dauer durchaus
auch mit sprengkraft für die ampel
danke für diese einschätzung ralf
schumacher auch beim fdp-parteitag das
bestimmende thema also der ukraine krieg
international laufen die bemühungen den
krieg zu beenden
kommende woche will un-generalsekretär
ish sowohl in russland mit präsident
putin als auch in der ukraine mit
präsident seelands gesprächen die
russische großoffensive auf den osten
des landes geht unvermindert weiter
antoine kurschilgen
feuer in einem krankenhaus in der stadt
bonn jetzt die klinik soll von einer
russischen rakete getroffen worden seien
moskaus truppen verstärken massiv ihre
angriffe im don was die ukrainisch
kontrollierten gebiete stehen offenbar
unter dauerbeschuss
die russischen streitkräfte haben mehr
als 1000 militärische ziele in der
ukraine angegriffen so der sprecher des
verteidigungsministeriums die schwersten
angriffe zielen demnach auf die
großstadt serie donetsk im gebiet
lugansk europäischen pro pasta und
marina werden bombardiert nördlich davon
versuchen die russischen truppen bei ist
um weiter nach süden vorzustoßen um die
ukrainischen truppen einzukesseln
laut britischen geheimdienst kommen sie
aber kaum voran weil das ukrainische
militär weiter heftigen widerstand
leistet der ukrainische präsident warnte
erneut der einmarsch russlands in die
ukraine sei nur der anfang
alle völker die wie wir an den sieg des
lebens über den tod glauben müssen mit
uns kämpfen sie müssen uns helfen denn
wir sind die ersten in der reihe und wer
wird der nächste sein fragt sie lenski
und reagiert damit auf aussagen des
russischen militärs von gestern demnach
sei das ziel die vollständige kontrolle
über den don bass und den süden der
ukraine um dann die republik moldau ins
visier zu nehmen die ukraine wäre dann
komplett vom schwarzen meer
abgeschnitten in der belagerten
hafenstadt mario pohl ist heute erneut
ein versuch gescheitert zivilisten zu
evakuieren nach ukrainischen angaben
haben dass russische truppen verhindert
moskau hatte bereits vor zwei tagen die
komplette eroberung von mario pohl
verkündet doch allem anschein nach
leisten ukrainische einheiten immer noch
widerstand und in der ukraine ist unser
reporter dominic löschmeister damit wie
reagiert die ukrainische regierung auf
die aussagen eines russischen vize
kommandeurs neben dem osten der ukraine
auch teile moldaus einigen zu wollen
ja der ukrainische präsident selensky
sagte das könnte nur der anfang sein die
sorge ist dass die russen nicht nur den
don bosco bahn wollen sondern auch den
süden der ukraine und hier speziell die
hafenstadt odessa und das heißt ja von
den russischen zaren gegründet worden
hat also auch für die russen eine
symbolik und eine bedeutung und wenn das
so wäre in diesem szenario dann würde es
auch eine verbindung geben zur teil
republik transnistrien
das ist gehört eigentlich zur republik
moldau wird aber von den russen
kontrolliert ist direkt im grenzgebiet
zur ukraine
und da ist natürlich jetzt die sorge
groß dass das verbunden wird und die
moldauer selbst das kein nato-mitglied
wie zum beispiel polen oder das baltikum
und deswegen ist dort die regierung auch
alarmiert und präsident selensky betonte
an der stelle noch einmal wie wichtig es
ist schwere waffen zu bekommen weil die
ukraine würde europas frieden
verteidigen danke da mäcklers meister
aus der ukraine
ihr seid hagen kommt die russische
großoffensive ost ukraine nur langsam
voran woran das liegt und welche rolle
schwere waffen bei den kämpfen spielen
können sie nachlesen auf zdf heute und
in der zdf- heute
mehr waffen für die ukraine das fordert
auch eine ukrainische delegation die
seit tagen quer durch europa reist heute
war sie zu besuch in nordrhein westfalen
teil der delegation ist ivan fedorov
mitte märz war der bürgermeister eine
besetzte stadt melle topoi im süden der
ukraine von russischen soldaten entführt
und wieder freigelassen worden thomas
münten hat ihn getroffen
fast wirkt ein bisschen verloren mit
seinem olivgrünen parka zwischen den
edlen gekleideten empfangskomitee um
düsseldorfer landtag die war im februar
auf bürgermeister der von der russischen
armee besetzten stadt melitta voll in
seine stadt zurück kann er nicht aber
werben kann er für mehr und schnellere
militärische hilfe für die ukraine
in der defense wir brauchen verteidigung
jetzt um die situation an der front zu
verändern wir hätten es gestern
gebraucht jetzt wäre es auch noch gut
aber morgen ist es vielleicht viel viel
zu spät
der 33 jährige der im märz von
russischen soldaten aus seinem werk haus
verschleppt und tagelang gefangen
gehalten wurde hier bilder einer
überwachungskamera hat keine zeit für
diplomatische zurückhaltung
politik
wir sind unterwegs um die deutschen
politik um eine klare entscheidung zu
finden stehen sie auf seiten der kabine
oder auf seiten der russischen
föderation
das müssen wir jetzt wissen
diese entscheidung haben rund 300
russischstämmige düsseldorf erinnern
bereits getroffen sie demonstrierten
heute auf der königsallee gegen wladimir
putin und seinen angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine wir glauben dass ohne den druck
von europa usa und den europäischen
ländern ist nicht dazu kommen wird dass
dieser krieg aufhört am nachmittag wurde
die beim fedorov von seiner kölner
amtskollegin henriette rieker empfangen
sie hatte sich vehement für seine
freilassung aus russischer
gefangenschaft eingesetzt
soweit zum krieg in der ukraine
was im realen leben illegal ist muss es
auch im netz sein hass hetze und betrug
etwa das klingt selbstverständlich ist
es aber nicht die eu hat sich deshalb
auf neue regeln geeinigt diese zum
beispiel online plattformen wie google
oder facebook müssen illegale inhalte
unverzüglich löschen und beim verdacht
auf schwere straftaten die behörden
informieren sie sind auch verpflichtet
nutzer zu sperren die häufig gegen die
regeln verstoßen und sie müssen offen
legen warum ihre algorithmen den nutzern
bestimmte inhalte empfehlen mehr von
gunnar grieger
ein eu schützt vor hass rede und setzt
das digitale dienste gesetz kurz dsa
gegen die internet lobby durch die eu
kommission meint ihr eigenes video wohl
nicht ganz ernst aber ihr anspruch ist
kaum kleiner
showdown war nachts um zwei einigung der
eu institutionen
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
nannte das historisch auf einer der nun
stärker regulierten plattformen
zustimmung von europaabgeordneten
es war notwendig dass wir eine klare
aussicht auch überblick bekommen und
dass wir auch hass im internet
konsequent bekämpfen können weniger
konsequent ist das gesetz bei der
verknüpfung von daten so sieht ein mann
mitte vierzig weiter personalisierte
werbung nur minderjährige sind davor
künftig besser geschützt
wenig konsequenz auch bei algorithmen
den regeln die bestimmen was nutzer
sehen und damit sie im staate auch
meinung nach solche media plattformen
setzen auf angst und wut warum tun sie
das weil die menschen dann länger im
internet bleiben und man kann ihn mehr
werbung zeigen und werbung ist das
geschäftsmodell des internets die
plattform verdienen also mehr geld mit
inhalten die uns polarisieren die uns
aufhetzen dem verdacht dürfen experten
nun per gesetz nachgehen die politik
kann die ergebnisse dann aufgreifen das
gesetz muss seinen anspruch also noch
einlösen in kraft tritt des frühesten
sind gut einem jahr
nach nordrhein westfalen hat wird am 15
mai ein neuer landtag gewählt und cdu
und spd liefern sich ein kopf an kopf
rennen derzeit regieren cdu und fdp das
bevölkerungsreichste bundesland für eine
wiederauflage scheint es laut umfragen
aber nicht zu reichen rot grün könnte es
knapp schaffen aber am
wahrscheinlichsten scheint ein
dreierbündnis heute läutete die cdu die
heiße wahlkampfphase ein mit
ministerpräsident wüst ein bericht von
ralph goldmann
er ist der amtierende ministerpräsident
und will es bleiben hendrik wüst ist cdu
spitzenkandidat in nordrhein westfalen
das amt hatte von armin laschet
übernommen das ist das erste mal dass er
um wählerstimmen werben muss geht jetzt
raus kämpft um jede stimme überzeugt die
menschen für unser land für die menschen
damit wir gemeinsam machen können worauf
es ankommt auch in den nächsten fünf
jahren auch er will ministerpräsident
werden oppositionsführer und
herausforderer thomas kutschaty hier
beim straßenwahlkampf in hagen seine spd
liegt in den jüngsten umfragen knapp vor
der cdu es gibt rückenwind auch die
umfragen sind gut das beflügelt
natürlich auch unsere wahlkämpferin und
wahlkämpfer da ist es auch kein problem
früh morgens um sechs am bahnhof zu
stehen und zu verteilen derzeit regiert
die cdu mit der fdp deren
spitzenkandidat joachim stamm will das
auch weiter tun auch wenn es wohl
schwierig wird mit einer neuauflage von
schwarz gelb unser ziel ist wieder
zweistellig zu werden und das ohne uns
keine mehrheit gebildet werden kann dass
wir weiter hier für wirtschaftswachstum
für individuelle bildung arbeiten können
laut aktuellen umfragen könnten aber die
grünen mit spitzenkandidatin mona
neubauer die fdp überflügeln eine
regierungsbeteiligung ist nicht
unwahrscheinlich
wir sind selbstbewusst und eigenständig
in diesem wahlkampf unterwegs und wir
werden um vertrauen für unsere gründen
inhalte werben und die dann auch
möglichst gewinnbringend in eine
künftige landesregierung einbringen auch
die ard wird wohl wieder im landtag
vertreten sein für spitzenkandidat
markus wagner ist aber klar eine
regierungsbeteiligung mit ihr will keine
der anderen parteien activity rolle
spielen die sie auch in der letzten
legislatur gespielt hat eine klare
opposition gegen die gesamte heilige
vielfältigkeit aus cdu spd fdp und
grünen wir werden dort immer den finger
in die wunde legen einer von ihnen wird
ministerpräsident werden hendrik wüst
oder thomas kutschaty es muss aber nicht
unbedingt der mit den meisten stimmen
sein sondern vielleicht der denn nach
der wahl mit den grünen und der fdp am
besten sondieren kann
zum sport schon heute am viertletzten
spieltag kann der fc bayern zum zehnten
mal nacheinander wohlgemerkt deutsche
fußball meister werden am anderen ende
tabelle ist ja schon der erste
entscheidung getroffen das bedrückt
viele fußballfans im frankenland denn
für die spielvereinigung greuther fürth
wird das abenteuer bundesliga nach nur
einer saison wieder zu ende gehen die
vorzeitige entscheidung fiel im eigenen
stadion 11 1 hat 1000 zuschauer sehen
das 1 4 gegen bayer leverkusen union
berlin referiert sich mit dem 2 2 1 in
leipzig für die pokalniederlage freiburg
gegen gladbach 3 zu 3 köln gewinnt gegen
bielefeld 3 zu 1 frankfurt gegen
hoffenheim 2 2
die bayern sind auf meisterkurs zur
halbzeit stets gegen dortmund
beziehungsweise kurz vor der pause zwei
zu null gestern wolfsburg gegen mainz
500 morgen noch zwei spiele die bayern
mit einem sieg gegen den bvb
uneinholbare zwölf-punkte-vorsprung
leverkusen jetzt vor leipzig freyburg
dich dran union und köln auf kurs zum
europäischen auftritt mainz jetzt in der
unteren hälfte für gladbach wolfsburg
und bochum ist zumindest der direkte
abstieg kein thema mehr bielefeld wird
gespannt auf das duell der besser
platzierten herthaner und stuttgarter
schauen führt verabschiedet sich am 14
mein bayern gvb das top spiel
schlechthin um 23 uhr ausführlich im
aktuellen sportstudio zu gast ist
frankfurts präsident peter fischer vom 1
weltmeister max verstappen gewinnt in
imola das erste sprint rennen des jahres
holt sich damit acht punkte und die
pole-position für den grand prix morgen
nachmittag
der niederländer verpasst den start die
räder drehen durch glück leer jetzt vorn
länder norris im mclaren kommt ihm
gefährlich nahe aber nicht vorbei der
ferrari vorne claire indes in führung
sebastian vettel wird nur dreizehnter im
grünen erst martin gestern im regen gut
aber seinen neunten startplatz können
nicht halten bottas im alfa romeo vorbei
und wenig später überholt ihn auch noch
mit schumacher im harz ferrari mit rang
zehn im sprint startet schumacher damit
beim grand prix so weit fahren wie noch
nie
überraschung am ende verstappen schnappt
sich eine runde vor schluss den sieg im
sprint volle claire und sergio perez
rekordsieger thw kiel steht nach dem 28
26 gegen lemgo zum fünfzehnten mal im
pokalfinale trifft morgen im hamburg im
gipfeltreffen auf bundesliga
spitzenreiter sc magdeburg
die halle ist voll die anfangsphase
torreich und magdeburg in weiß rose
drehen wie es der
bundesliga-tabellenführung entspricht
gesten die christians von 13 zu 9 1 4
tore vorsprung der bis zur halbzeit
bleibt da stets 17 13 erlangen kommt
über die außenseiterrolle nicht hinaus
antonio metzner zum 17 14 kleiner wird
der rückstand nicht mehr heißt es trifft
dann zum endstand 30 22 am sonntag im
finale gegen den elfmaligen pokalsieger
kiel hat magdeburg die chance den ersten
von zwei möglichen saison titeln klar zu
machen
dass morgen in der sportstudio reportage
dankeschön die wetteraussichten die
kommen gleich von katja horneffer so
viel aber schon mal vorab die natur die
kann den wegen regen vielerorts brauchen
dennoch regnet es morgen keineswegs
überall das heute-journal läuft heute um
22.45 mit christian sievers auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
island hat eigentlich ein abo auf tiefs
aber derzeit dreht sich dort ein hoch
und die tief ziehen über mitteleuropa
schon heute gab es ja regenschauer und
gewitter und in der zweiten nachthälfte
breiten sich regenfälle von der schweiz
und von frankreich aus über
süddeutschland aus und morgen regnet es
dann am längsten hier im thüringer wald
oder auch in baden württemberg heute
nacht ist es auch mal klar im östlichen
sachsen und zwischen der ostseeküste und
dem sauerland und die temperaturen
sinken auf 10 bis 3 grad die größten
temperaturunterschiede auf engem raum
gibt es morgen in der mitte deutschlands
nur acht grad werden es in der oberpfalz
18 grad dagegen am niederrhein sonst
liegen die temperaturen zwischen 9 und
16 grad und in süddeutschland fällt
häufig regen da bleibt es meist bedeckt
zwischen der mosel dem oberrhein den
thüringer wald und im erzgebirge
zwischen dem bayerischen wald und im
allgäu aber entwickeln sich schauer und
gewitter bei westwind da sehen sie also
auch mal die sonne viel mehr sonne sehen
sie morgen in norddeutschland da wird es
freundlich bei einem immer noch
kräftigen wind aus nordost wechselhaft
startet dann auch die neue woche aber
bis mittwoch setzt sich dann doch schon
fast überall wieder die sonne durch bei
milderen 12 bis 18 grad schönes
wochenende